[Musique]
assécher les migrations pour assimiler
deuxièmement assimilés ça veut dire
service national interdiction du voile
dans les universités
cela veut dire interdiction du voile
dans les entreprises dans les services
publics c'est à dire il faut libérer la
femme
moi je suis très inquiète de l'état du
débat dans notre pays
ça devient totalement délirant et on est
plus sur la raison on est sous le coup
de l'émotion avec un espèce de concours
lépine pour savoir qui aura la meilleure
idées d'extrême droite on peut les citer
ce qu'on appelle communément l'islamo
gauchisme c'est des ravages il fait des
ravages à l'université il fait des
ravages quand une organisation comme
l'unef céda à ceux à ce type de chose il
fait des ravages quand dans les rangs de
la france insoumise vous avez des gens
qui sont tout simplement de ce courant
et s'affichent comme tel ministre d'état
monsieur darmon qui nous expliquent
qu'il faudrait fermer les rayons halal
monsieur fillon monsieur ciotti qui nous
expliquent qu'il faudrait interdire le
voile partout dans l'espace public
est ce que vous croyez que cela est de
nature à calmer la situation et à ne pas
attiser les haines et avancer vers la
guerre civile
l'épidémie a flambé dans l'immense
majorité de notre pays hier dans notre
pays il ya eu plus de 2000 patients
hospitalisés et plus de 250 patients
hospitalisés en réanimation
ça fait presque une hospitalisation par
minute d'ailleurs depuis que j'ai
commencé à parler il ya cinq personnes
qui sont à l'hôpital
désormais tous les départements de
france ont dépassé le seuil d alerte
soit 50 cas pour 100000 habitants pour
la première fois santé publique france a
dévoilé hier soir plusieurs indicateurs
à l'échelle de la commune et plus
seulement au niveau de la région du
département de la métropole
à ce stade pas de confinement prévu du
pays que toutes les mesures comprend
vise à empêcher en confinement du pays
mais comprendra toujours les mesures
nécessaires pour protéger la santé des
français
cette progression de l'épidémie nous
conduit à étendre les mesures de
couvre-feu à 38 nouveaux départements et
à un territoire d'outre-mer la polynésie
y aura-t-il des fêtes de noël cette
année
évidemment tu auras défaites deux en
famille normalement masqué mais la
question c'est est ce qu'on évitera un
couvre-feu noël c'est ça qu'on veut
absolument éviter évidemment et zabeth
martichoux c'est pour ça qu'on prend
toutes ces mesures
au total à compter de vendredi minuit ce
sont 54 départements et un territoire
d'outre-mer qui seront soumis à la règle
du couvre feu soit 46 millions de nos
concitoyens
l'objectif du gouvernement tout faire
pour éviter un confinement
comme en irlande où toute la population
r- confiné depuis hier soir pour six
semaines à dublin
les rues sont désertes de jour comme de
nuit un air de déjà vu
les semaines qui viennent seront durs
non services hospitaliers vont être mis
à rude épreuve et le nombre de morts va
continuer d'augmenter le mois de
novembre sera éprouvant nous le savons
déjà
fab françois favorable à une union
civile pour les couples homosexuels dans
un documentaire diffusé hier dans le
cadre du festival international du film
de rome le souverain pontife s'exprime
longuement à ce sujet je cite ce sont
des enfants de dieu les personnes
homosexuelles en droit à une famille
les restrictions sanitaires plus ou
moins respecté dans le monde du
libertinage effectivement existe avec le
club grec là pour le coup c'est assez
compliqué quand un exemple avec le club
échangiste effectivement pas le voir à
la villa des anges cédant pas de cas
liés à la villa des changes qui vient de
fermer pour 15 jours gros coup dur pour
l'om qui va devoir absolument revoir
séparer ce week-end le week-end sept
mois de fermeture ont eu raison de 30%
des boîtes de nuit du pays qui serait
aujourd'hui selon la profession placée
en redressement judiciaire
dans le monde de la nuit c'est le sauve
qui peut
le sauna libertin jaurès à orléans a
reçu les félicitations de la police mais
oui dans les risques et enfin attention
à leurs cours d'histoire et les
autorités ont constaté que tout était
nickel notamment le port du masque sur
la quarantaine de personnes une personne
a été sanctionné bravo selon les plus
pessimistes des estimations 9 boîte de
nuit sur dix auront disparu d'ici l'été
prochain